>> All right. Let's start off with an introduction
to--of yourselves, your company, and your
product.
>> JIMENEZ: Okay. My name is John Jimenez.
I'm a senior manager for Web services for
Citrix. Our product that we're demoing here
at Google I/O is Citrix T.V. Website, which
is kind of an enterprise version of YouTube
for Citrix and its partners and its employees.
>> LIPTAY: And I'm Albert Liptay, principle
Web developer and I do a lot of the plumbing
on the back end and on the [INDISTINCT].
>> Okay. So you're using the Google Web Toolkit.
What were some of the reasons for you to choose
that platform?
>> JIMENEZ: We chose Google Web Toolkit for
a couple of different reasons. We've been
evaluating the technology for a little while.
It was sort of in the back of our minds as
we were sort of evaluating new projects as
they were coming along. But like the keynote
from yesterday, the guy who was demoing the--actually,
from this morning--the Wave project. He said,
you know, very publicly, he wouldn't have
been able to do the project without GWT. I
feel the same way. We had started sort of
evaluating it. We thought it was a neat thing
and sort of put it on the shelf until Citrix
had to do a resizing and we lost a lot the
skill set that we would have needed to do
the project. So it allowed us to take a lot
of guys who are really talented, Java developers
and allowed them to become really talented
JavaScript and AJAX developers. So without
GWT, I don't think this project would have
gotten off the ground.
>> All right. Any major check up for challenges
or cool war stories using the product?
>> LIPTAY: No, we sat down at the beginning
of the offset of the project and said, "Are
we committed?" And I think we both agreed
that we wanted to go the distance. So we basically
surmounted all the hurdles we had.
>> JIMENEZ: It was a--it was a different sort
of mindset going in to--to the developing
a GWT application. And I think once we got
our mind around how GWT works, I think, everything
worked well after that. And coming from Web
1.0 and a JavaScript development paradigm
into the GWT paradigm, once we got our minds
right, I think, it was all easy. But getting
there, it took a little bit.
>> LIPTAY: And one thing to mention too is
that, you know, everyone here at the conference
ask me running the features, but reality is,
it really works and it works well.
>> So speaking of features, what are some
of your favorite features of the Web Toolkit?
>> JIMENEZ: So I ended up rolling up my sleeves
and took off my manager hat and put on my
developer hat, and I became a UI developer,
you know. Like I said, we went through sort
of a re-org and we loss our two more--most
talented sort of UI JavaScript developers.
So I ended up building widgets and doing all
those things. And for me, you know, the hosted
mode, being able to do the debugging the application
and my clips debugger, that was amazing. I
never, you know, my--in my career as a developer,
I've always hated the JavaScript tools, I've
always that, you know, I've never liked Venkman,
I've never liked some of the JavaScript debuggers.
So being able to debug an application in my
native debugger, you know, which is my Eclipse
debugger, I think, that by itself was worth,
you know, whatever pains we had to go through
to sort of embrace it.
>> What about you Albert?
>> LIPTAY: And for me I would say that, you
know, we have Spring MVC on the back end and
using the RPC out of this box makes it very,
very pleasant and it's great work.
>> So an extension of the feature topic, what
are some features you would like to see in
GWT?
>> JIMENEZ: New feature for GWT, well, we're
pretty excited about the features that were
announced here, the code splitting. We've
already sort of moved to 1.6 but, you know,
we've been hearing the--a little bit of buzz
about what's going to happen in 2.0. The ability
to run your hosted mode in any browser, not
just a host of browser, I think that will
be big especially for guys who are pushing
pixels, right? The guys that are doing the
MVC stuff and the RPC stuff, I think, they're
not as affected by, you know, opening up the
hosted-mode browser and waiting and then compiling
it and then bringing up, you know, your, your
Firebug and all of that. And if you could
just do that directly in Firebug right away,
I think that would be huge. That would save
me a quarter of my day.
>> LIPTAY: And I would have to say better
Maven support. I don't think Google quite
embraces Maven. It's a level that we would
hope secondly on, I don't know.
>> JIMENEZ: I do have one suggestion or something
that sort of, is always in the back of my
mind when I'm working with GWT is that--how
am I doing? Oh, sorry. So a suggestion for
the GWT team is that, I feel that the way
that J2EE sort of didn't get a take off until
there was some structure around Web development,
I really feel that the catalyst for J2EE to
take off was like Struts or Web works or these
frame works that really sprung up because
it was sort of the wild-wild west out there.
I feel that that's sort of analogous to what's
going on right now with GWT. If there was
sort of a more structured way of implementing
your applications, I think, that would sort
of funnel people down the same path and I
think it would be more, more traction and
I think it would be embraced, you know.
>> So do you have any advice for people just
getting started in GWT?
>> JIMENEZ: Yeah. So some advice for some
folks starting out. For us we went from the,
from the Web 1.0 model, right, where we had
our wire frames, we had our high fidelity
mock ups, and then we had some guys coding
html pages. When we started with GWT, it was
such a different mindset for us so we just
started coding Java right away and figuring
out what the right widgets were and figuring
out the hierarchy of widgets and the call
models and all of that, I think, that was
sort of painful for us. So I think we would
want to--if we started over today, I think
we would start back to the low fidelity prototypes
into the high fidelity prototypes and then
actually creating html, looking at the html
and then abstracting out what really should
be a widget instead of coding in Java and
seeing how it renders into html, sort of going
back to, sort of the previous model and sort
of finding a common place, right?
>> LIPTAY: Yeah. And I think that's one thing
Google is, it's not really easy to know what
libraries, precision libraries are out there
for widgets, like, completing a special table,
like, you have to search and you're like,
well, does anyone else use this table, and
it's sort of, same thing goes with [INDISTINCT].
It turns out, a lot of people are using G.I.N.,
but just strolling the Web, you just don't
like that stuff after...
>> Okay, John and Albert, I want to thank
you for your time and sharing with us today.
>> JIMENEZ: Thank you.
>> LIPTAY: Thank you.